my name is Mabel I'm 23 I'm a singer I'm
Swedish English Sierra Leonean having a
mixed heritage shaped me as a person
growing up I would you spend a lot of
time at home or like with a few friends
writing songs seeing harmonies I was a
teenager that had quite a lot of anxiety
and depression and things like that and
my parents were just like you know lots
of people feel this way with parents
that are musicians I was inspired by
them they encouraged me can very young
age to be creative music has been my
therapy it's crazy how much confidence
it's given me making songs and the
journey that I've been on over the last
few years of actually putting music out
has given me more confidence than I've
had in my whole life you're so lucky
that I grew up in an age of independent
woman survivor
I feel like it made me very sassy in a
good way you know the music that I grew
up listening to with the incredible
female role models that I had telling me
that I was more than enough and that I
didn't need a man and all those things
have shaped me and that's a message that
I feel like I need to carry on for my
listeners there's a lot of challenges
for females in the industry studio
environments are still very
male-dominated I think it's just
important to encourage young females to
dare to get in those rooms because it
can be really intimidating we're all
different or unique letting go of that
thing of comparing yourself to other
people is a big way to gain your
confidence beauty is really important to
me and obviously I'm always myself but
how I do my glam helps me be that person
on stage where confidence to me is being
comfortable in yourself
we're all supporting each other we're
stronger when we're together which I
just always keep big in each other up
but I don't see why we would do anything
else to watch more videos like this
subscribe to the glamour UK channel now